well this week resorts all along the
strip kicking off pool season this comes
just in time for our spring and summer
months which typically of course
drawing those large crowds to the
various pools and
day clubs now we went to mgm grant a bit
earlier today to take a look
inside for your next pool day
las vegas and pool season go hand in
hand here at mgm they're balancing
safety restrictions while making sure
guests can relax
after a long year mgm grand is one of
the first
properties to open up their pools this
week there's a 50
capacity limit with no more than six
people to a group
i do like how they i'm consistently
seeing people sanitizing and cleaning
the
benches and the layout stuff which is
really puts you at ease
many day clubs will reopen as an
extension of the main pools with
reservations needed as
masks continue to be required on resort
properties
one question on everyone's mind are
masks required in the pool
when you're in the pool you can remove
your mask when you're walking to and
from to get in the pool you can remove
your mask
and of course when you're actively
eating food or drinking a beverage which
a lot of us do at the pool you can
remove your mask john flynn with mgm
resorts is expecting quite a bit of
demand for pool season
saying widespread vaccinations are
giving people a renewed sense of
optimism
when you look around the country right
you can't really travel internationally
right now there's only one or two places
to go
to really celebrate and have fun las
vegas is it in addition to mgm
many pools are reopening all along the
strip guests can make reservations for
the pools at treasure island the
cosmopolitan the strat and
encore beach club really good to see
that it's getting back to a place of
where people
can really just enjoy themselves kate
houston 8 news now